joining me here on the mercedes-benz
vans phone line is a man who's got new
episodes of the freak brothers airing on
sundays only on to be a highly acclaimed
adult animated comedy adventure series
and he's also currently in production
for season two of the hit show on hulu
called woke blake anderson back here on
the rich eisen show how are you blake
i'm doing well what's up dude
i am just hanging out hanging out just
feeling good i went to the university of
michigan so them beating up ohio state
over the weekend i'm still buzzing you
know yeah
a lot of people a lot of people are
really emotional and happy and sad my
gosh what a what a game well i'm on the
uh i'm on the uh the happy and emotional
not the sad part of it you know okay
good that's what i'm doing but i was
rooting for you you know what i'm i'm
happy for you too uh blake because i
know you're a die hard warriors fan and
it looks like the the warriors days of
your which isn't too far ago but it
looks like you're back looks like the
warriors
oh my gosh well i i mean
i feel like us warrior fans we we were
watching this team you know and the last
two seasons although the record was uh
you know kind of look like they weren't
the squad that they are today we saw
coming they they they just had a chance
to really throw a lot of their players
into like
in-game situations and they just
developed their players so quickly and
now look at us we're just a super deep
squad i'm loving it yeah i know again as
i mentioned i went to the university of
michigan jordan poole is uh is a
michigan wolverine and he has been
phenomenal
so far this year it's like in the last
two seasons he's just found so much
confidence it's like he swears he's the
the splash triplet
i know that well because the the brother
is coming back too so clay is right
around the corner i imagine poole will
return to the bench um uh and and will
be one of those six men dynamos because
clay's coming back steph looks like he's
23 not 33. and draymond is the hall of
fame uh uh you know distributor and
doing all the glue work
it's amazing it's amazing i mentioned
not to mention wiggins comes out of
nowhere and is just like a beast every
other game so it's just like i don't
know everything's clicking i hope they
can just you know ride this this energy
the whole season because right now they
are the team to beat wiseman is coming
back too i mean this is uh it's all
coming up warriors right now and i'm you
know i'm wondering what so when you grew
up in northern california what was that
was that the
the run uh
tmc
version of was that the with the
hardaway and chris mullen
uh warriors that you were and mitch
richman warriors when you were growing
up
i was on the tail end of that i was kind
of ushered in during like the spree well
years and then that kind of turned into
like the weber years that's right and
then after that it it got kind of dark
and not very good
uh
i was a big latrell spreewell fan like
spree for three that was that was my guy
he's still up there in my my warriors
hall of fame for sure three for three so
you know i did my uh local market
television work in reading california
blake
yeah way up of way up i-5 so you're from
concord right is that your original
hometown in california that is correct
okay so i grew up there for 18 years so
why not a kings fan why why why don't
you go there hey i've got love for the
kings man i was there for that run i i
still am a you know they got the worst
end of all the referees being cheaters
that they should have beat los angeles
lakers like that team
was a championship team that's robbery
so were you one of those folks with a
cowbell behind the the bench banging it
uh
making phil jackson all angry was that
you blake were you one of those folks
i wish i i i'll say that was like maybe
i was related to one of those people i
hope that was one of my crazy uncles
maybe it could be that blake anderson
here uh on the rich eisen show the freak
brothers on sundays only on to be what
walk me through this because you're in
it and you're also an executive producer
of it
what what's going on with this one that
people are talking about so um the freak
brothers the fabulous furry freak
brothers is actually like a super
legendary like underground comic from
the 1970s um
and it's just like i don't know
they have a huge fan base from back in
the day and and like the comic is just
hilarious there's tons of them they they
hold up they're super funny
and it's kind of like one of those
things that especially in today's day
and age where everything is getting
remade and all that when i was reading
these comics it was like
how is this not a cartoon there's just
such a wealth of like
comedy and ideas in the books
so when i when i heard that there was an
opportunity that to actually attach
myself to the cartoon i i just
absolutely jumped at the chance i mean
it's it's it's everything you'd want
it's just the the best form of stoner
comedy it's like up there with cheech
and chong well and that's it
maybe that's the allure of woody
harrelson jumping on board too huh on to
that that's exactly it because actually
well adam devine like my best buddy who
i did workaholics with and he's also a
producer on
on freak brothers he actually does a
show uh the righteous gemstones with
john goodman who does the voice of fat
freddy on freak brothers and he was kind
of like
you know reading the comics adam was
reading the comics on set
just you know catching up on the
material just because we were
producing it and john goodman actually
saw that and he's like whoa like where
the heck did you find freak brothers and
adam's like oh well we're producing
we're gonna make a cartoon he's like
you gotta you gotta include me i was a
huge fan when i was young and i wanna i
wanna be a part of it and and then that
just kind of snowballed into the
incredible cast we got it's just like
mind-blowing tiffany haddish pete
davidson um andrea savage who i love she
is hilarious
and and you and adam devine just to name
a few uh on this show yeah yeah all you
know hollywood is murmuring they they're
saying it's a stronger cast than
avengers you know i believe it hollywood
is murmuring is another one of my
favorite tv shows it's a great show man
yeah i like that undercover for sure the
free the freak brothers only sundays
only on on to be uh i wanna we play
celebrity true or false with some of our
celebrity guests blake you qualify on
that front for sure on this
show uh uh where we go through your
history and whether what's online about
you is true or false would you mind
playing that with me right now
let's do it i'm not afraid maybe i am a
little afraid okay here we go we'll do
it but either way just jump into the
abyss here's uh here we even have some
production value for you go for it hit
it please
celebrity true or false you can't handle
the truth
all right there you go that's that's it
for the production volume uh first one
first one up for you true or false blake
anderson your first tv gig was doing
backyard wrestling on public access in
your hometown of concord california as a
character known as rockabilly rex true
or false absolutely 100
true i was recognized at my movie
theater job tearing tickets so it that
makes it a success to me huh so what
movies were you tearing tickets for back
in the day
well i worked at a local theater brendan
theaters and uh probably the
the coolest movie that was in the
theater at the time was kings of comedy
with bernie mac and steve harvey and d.l
hugley and cedric the entertainer and
that's where we're trying to we're
trying to peg exactly when this was when
you were rockabilly rex and i guess that
leads into our next one true or false
that you had back surgery after
fracturing your spine during a house
party when you jumped from your roof
onto a beer pong table is that true or
false blake anderson that is also
unfortunately very true yeah i thought i
would uh kind of nba jam slam dunk uh a
final beer pong ball
into the cup i jumped off the roof try
to make it look cool ended up looking
pretty stupid but we're up and we're
walking today so thank y'all hey
how about you learn how how how how much
of a drop off the roof was it blake um i
don't know i it was just like off of
i did i would say 13 feet but let's say
it was 30 just to make it cooler that
does make it sound a little bit more
frightening okay so you're right
basically are those two things con
connected your backyard wrestling and
your your beer pong table roof jumping
those are connected oh for sure i mean
there's a reason that before you watch
pro wrestling shows now they're like
don't try this at home i'm the i'm the
reason uh next one uh true or false
you're a pizza delivery man in college
and occasionally would heist a pepperoni
or two off the delivery pizza without
anybody knowing true or false
absolutely westwood california i served
up uh plenty of ucla bruins and
the rumors are true they don't tip that
well
come on who did you who did you deliver
to who which bruins did you deliver to
football basketball which ones
which uh but by the looks of it it was
probably like a wrestling team i don't
know uh
i would i would hope that the the
basketball players would be balling more
but uh i was usually
asked to be paid in bond grips and you
know i have to pay the rent but i i did
accept sometimes i you know that leads
us to freak brothers right
it's all connected it's like a tapestry
you're waving together blake uh no
question about that uh last one for you
true or false for the entire first
season of war of workaholics you and
adam devine actually lived in the house
where your characters live in the show
you were convinced the show was going to
get cancelled so you did it to save
money is that true or false for
workaholics
it's absolutely true not only to save
money but to literally have
uh comedy central pay our rent while i
while we live there they were paying
for us
to live there because that was the set
of the show it was pretty ingenious and
it just so happened that it worked out
that we got more seasons so
living rent free so you basically said
did did comedy central know that you
were tenants as well as uh employees
contracted employees did they know it
was kind of like a two for one where we
were also like set security so nothing
would get stolen it was like 24 hours
surveillance perfect so when we're
watching workaholics and the place had
that lived in look it's because it
literally was being lived in by you and
adam devon that's exactly right oh yeah
it was like a running joke anytime there
would be dirty dishes in the sink we'd
be like definitely don't do the dishes
because it's continuity you have to keep
them dirty
continuity wishes oh man exactly
fantastic blake anderson thank you for
the call greatly appreciate it um the uh
the new season of woke on hulu's
currently in production and the freak
brothers congratulations on that uh
there's a reason why everybody's talking
about it thanks for the call yeah thank
you so much you got it at uncle blazer
on twitter and again that is not i don't
think the portland trailblazer reference
and at blake anderson on instagram blake
anderson here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here